quand j'étais petit sur les plages de la
baule et de la côte sauvage
nous remontions souvent avec des
galettes de mazout sous les pieds
aujourd'hui il ya plus de galettes de
mazout mais il ya une pollution bien
plus insidieuse le plastique
quand j'étais petit sur les plages de la
baule et de la côte sauvage je
farfouille est entre les rochers pour
pêcher des crevettes ou dans la vase
pour pêcher des palourdes je m'amusais
entre les doigts faire éclater les
véhicules des gourmands
aujourd'hui plus de crevettes quasiment
plus de palourdes
plus de l'ong d'algues brunes les
rochers sont à nu
les tempêtes sont de plus en plus
fréquentes on trouve des arbres à terre
des ardoises arrachés
l'année dernière un volet de notre
maison familiale a été arraché
un pan du mur de nos voisins s'étaient
écroulés dans la mer
l'érosion avait eu raison du mur
d'enceinte
la situation est urgente elle est
importante
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
consacre la majorité de mon temps à la
mer et plus précisément à la fondation
de la mer
la fondation de la mer s'engage avec
tous ceux qui le souhaitent des citoyens
des ong et scientifiques les navigateurs
pour que nous ayons une mer protégez
libre est valorisé avec sagesse
la mer l'océan c'est 70% de la surface
de la planète
un espace en 3d dans lequel se déploie
la vie des millions d'organismes un
espace totalement méconnu
d'ailleurs à chaque l'expédition
scientifique les chercheurs découvrent
des nouvelles espèces
certes non pas d'immense mammifères
marins non des organismes microscopiques
du zooplancton du phytoplancton
qui sont qui sont absolument majeur
parce qu'ils sont à la source même de la
vie dans l'océan ils sont à la base de
toute la chaîne alimentaire dans l'océan
et cette vie dans l'océan est en danger
20 % des récifs coralliens ont déjà
disparu un quart pourraient disparaître
dans les décennies à venir
un tiers des mammifères marins est en
voie d'extinction
qu'allons nous faire pour ces espèces et
pour notamment toutes les espèces qui
vont disparaître avant même que nous
ayons eu la chance de les découvrir
il faut protéger la vie dans l'océan il
faut protéger la vie de l'humanité
c'est urgent
c'est important
l'océan avec son énorme volume d'eau
avec le phytoplancton et le régulateur
du climat
il absorbe un tiers du co2 que nous
émettons il promet il le produit 50% de
l'oxygène de l'atmosphère
il a absorbé 90% de l'excès de chaleur
que nous avons produites par nos
activités humaines
alors que se passera-t-il si un jour
l'océan ne peut plus jouer ce rôle
la situation est urgente
elle est importante
vous le savez tous fini dans l'océan
toutes nos pollutions les visibles les
invisibles
tous ces déchets que nous ne prenons pas
la peine le temps de trier
depuis je vous parle ce sont pas loin de
40 tonnes de plastique qui ont été
déversées dans l'océan quelque part sur
la planète il faut stopper cette horreur
c'est urgent c'est important
vous connaissez peut-être sever de
charles baudelaire homme libre femme
libre
toujours tu chériras la mer
la liberté pour moi c'est le coeur de
mon amour pour l'océan
il vient d'un couple d'amis de mes
parents christophe et christine qui
habitait en allemagne à la psi à
l'époque c'était l'allemagne de l'est
sous joug soviétique
tous les étés christine venait avec ses
enfants passer deux semaines de vacances
avec mon frère a semé soeur et moi
christophe lui ne pouvait pas quitter
l'allemagne de l'est il était professeur
de théologie pasteur donc à la psi et
puis une année je me souviens plus très
bien quand au milieu des années 80 il a
reçu l'autorisation de partir avec sa
femme et ses enfants
je me souviens encore de l'émotion qui
l'a saisie quand nous l'avons emmené en
mer
pas de murs pas de frontières nulle
autorisation à demander il a éprouvé ce
sentiment incroyable de pouvoir naviguer
vers l'horizon en toute liberté
alors christophe je pense à toi chaque
fois que je vais en mer merci de m'avoir
fait découvrir ce que signifie la
liberté en mer
d'autant plus que cette liberté est
aujourd'hui menacé on le voit avec la
mer d'azov avec la mer noire les chinois
font la même chose en mer de chine
méridionale
des centaines de bateaux industriels
vont intimider les petits pêcheurs
artisanaux
des câbles sous-marins sont sabotés bref
la sécurité la liberté en mer ne sont
plus la norme
la situation est importante elle est
urgente aussi
à évidemment devant toutes ces menaces
et je vous ai même pas parlé de la pêche
illicite illégale et de la surpêche ça
pourrait faire l'objet d'une conférence
ted à elle toute seule devant toutes ces
menaces il faut se révolter s'indigner
dénoncer mais ça ne suffit pas
il faut agir
depuis plus de 30 ans j'évolue dans le
monde de l'entreprise je suis dirigeante
est actionnaire d'entreprises
je suis émerveillée devant la qualité
des produits que nous proposons à nos
clients
impressionné par le travail de nos
collaborateurs très fiers de créer de
l'emploi en france
mais ce que j'aime par dessus tout c'est
l'esprit entrepreneurial
cette faculté de regarder chaque
situation même les plus délicates comme
une opportunité de faire mieux de faire
différemment
et c'est la manière dont nous
fonctionnons à la fondation de la mer
nous prenons le temps de la réflexion de
l'étude de l'analyse et puis nous
agissons nous agissons par tous les
moyens
parce que chacun peut agir
et ici en bretagne
le pire est arrivé fin 99 peut-être
certains d'entre vous s'en souviennent
c'était le naufrage de l'erika
les plages les rochers étaient couverts
de pétrole
les oiseaux aux ailes englué ne pouvait
plus voler
c'était atroce que qu'il s'est il passé
ensuite
d'abord un vaste plan de rénovation
écologique nous nous sommes tous
mobilisés pour nettoyer et remettre en
état ses rivages souillés
et puis des réglementations
internationales
ça a marché ça a marché
80 et ce pour cent des pollutions
pétrolières depuis les années 70 se sont
déroulés avant 1999
à l'époque il y avait environ 40 marée
noire par an
aujourd'hui il y en a environ 2 ces deux
de trop bien sûr mais quel chemin a été
parcouru
alors oui nous pouvons agir
chacun peut agir et la première action
que nous pouvons mettre en oeuvre ces de
s'informer et de se former
c'est ce que vous faites en écoutant
cette conférence ted c'est ce que je
fais régulièrement en écoutant des
podcasts de scientifiques le cnrs
l'ifremer la marine nationale
et c'est important parce que la mer est
une grande inconnue
savez vous par exemple
que les coraux sont des animaux oui
chaque brin de corail
c'est un squelette qui rassemble des
millions d'animaux minuscule ensemble
ces animaux secrète un squelette en
calcaire commun
savez vous que les algues peuvent
fleurir
les scientifiques appellent cela le
bloom ou l'efflorescence algal la mer
devient alors rouge ou vert fluo on l'a
vu ici il ya quelques années en bretagne
généralement ce n'est pas dangereux pour
la santé humaine mais si ces phénomènes
se renouvellent trop régulièrement c'est
le signe d'un dérèglement de l'océan
savez vous que le requin est dangereux
pour l'homme le requin est dangereux
pour l'homme chaque année le requin tu
pardon nord car l'homme est dangereux
pour le requin
l'homme est dangereux pour le requin
chaque année le requin tu une dizaine de
personnes par an chaque année l'homme tu
100 millions de requins par an certes on
ne pêche pas et ne se nourrit pas de 100
millions de requins en on sort les
requins de l'eau on leur coupe l'aileron
et ils sont rejetés à l'eau les
condamnant à une mort certaine
l'homme est dangereux pour le requin
savez-vous qu'on ne peut pas ramasser le
plastique en mer
on adorerait remet à ramasser le
plastique en mer mais la réalité c'est
que lorsque le plastique arrive en mer
il se décompose très rapidement de
macrodéchets en micro déchets et en
nanoparticules
les filets
quels qu'ils soient ne peuvent pas
ramasser ces plastiques aujourd'hui les
meilleures techniques qui existent
permet de ramasser en une journée la
quantité de plastique qui est déversée
en 3,3 secondes
imaginez que c'est impossible de
ramasser le plastique en mer
alors si c'est impossible de ramasser le
plastique en mer que peut-on faire
eh bien il faut le ramasser à terre
pourquoi parce que 80% du plastique que
l'on retrouve dans l'océan vient de la
terre on appelle cela la pollution
tellurique la pollution qui vient de la
mer
comme citoyen on peut agir
par exemple vous pouvez vous inscrire à
une collecte de déchets vous allez sur
le site un geste pour la mère de la
fondation de la mer il ya 200 250
associations partout sur le territoire
qui organise plusieurs collectes par an
vous participez ainsi à la mobilisation
de millions milliers de personnes qui
contribuent à lutter contre la pollution
à terre
vous pouvez aussi soutenir un
éco-citoyen ce sont des jeunes
aventuriers qui mène des aventures pour
sensibiliser à l'aide à la pollution
plastique moi j'aime beaucoup anne elle
anaëlle ya deux ans avait longé tout le
tout le littoral méditerranéen à vélo et
en kayak et à chaque étape elle
organisait une collecte de déchets
et la sensibilisation du grand public
l'année dernière
anna elle a descendu la loire toujours à
vélo et en kayak et c'est solène qui l'a
remplacé sur le littoral méditerranéen
cette année elles ont été rejointes par
philomène philomène c'est une nageuse et
une coureuse alors elle va aller du lac
léman jusqu'à menton toujours en
organisant des collectes
vous pouvez aussi vous procurer des
produits issus de l'up cycling loeb
cycling c'est la manière de transformer
des déchets en des produits qui peuvent
être utiles alors des
par exemple des masques ça je pense à
clément clément ils organisent le masque
et on y court et en courant et ramassent
des masques avec ses copains et ensuite
il transforme tous les masques onu
devrait panoplie des sacs des maillots
de bain et même des robes de princesse
vous essayez dans les écoles parce que
parler aux enfants les mobiliser leur
expliquer comment ils peuvent contribuer
c'est extrêmement important
et puis vous pouvez si vous le préférez
aller choisir une espèce en particulier
que vous avez envie de protéger
les requins des orques des d'autres
mammifères marins
des poisson demoiselle dans les coraux
moi ce que j'aime en particulier c'est
le diable de mer
le diable de metz est une cousine de la
raie manta tropicale elle vit en
méditerranée il est peu probable que
vous en ayez jamais rencontré une
pourquoi parce qu'elle est en voie
d'extinction et la fondation de la mer
nous soutenons une association qui
cherche à comprendre les modes de
reproduction et de vie de l'arrêt de la
du diable de mer pour justement pouvoir
mieux le protéger
puis vous allez me dire en fait je passe
la majorité de mon temps au travail que
puis-je faire quand je suis au boulot
c'est aussi la question je me suis posé
comme chef d'entreprise
alors il ya un certain nombre de choses
assez simples qui au fond permettent de
réconcilier l'économie et l'écologie
regardez les emballages
réduits à la consommation de co2 on n'a
pas besoin d'être en tee shirt en plein
hiver dans son bureau
réfléchir à la l'idée de consommer de
produire localement
installé dans son bureau un panneau la
mer commence ici
évidemment toutes les entreprises n'ont
pas les mêmes impacts sur l'océan et
c'est pour ça la fondation de la mer que
nous avons développé des outils qui
permettent aux entreprises de d'évaluer
leur impact sur l'océan et puis de les
valoriser et d'agir par exemple pour un
hôtel
l'enjeu c'est la consommation d'eau
comment réduite on la consommation d'eau
dans l'hôtel c'est également le type de
poisson qui est utilisé dans le
restaurant ce sont les babioles en
plastique dans les chambres dans l'est
dans les salles de bains
si vous êtes une agence de publicité
vous pouvez influer vos influences et
vos clients sur les messages qu'ils font
passer aux consommateurs vous pouvez
décider de tourner vos publicités en
france
si vous êtes une municipalité vous
pouvez équiper vos agents municipaux de
triporteurs électriques vous pouvez
rénover les bâtiments pour qu'ils
consomment moins d'énergie vous pouvez
vous assurer que les entreprises avec
lesquelles vous travaillez
mesure leur impact sur l'océan et ont
une stratégie océans
alors vous voyez c'est facile d'agir
parce que tout est lié avec l'océan le
climat la biodiversité
la manière de produire et de consommer
et c'est ce que j'essaye de faire comme
citoyenne comme consommatrice comme
dirigeante d'entreprise et comme
présidente de la fondation de la mer
alors pour conclure
j'aimerais partager avec vous un rêve et
puis vous demander une faveur
mon rêve c'est que quand nos enfants nos
petits enfants feront leurs premiers pas
sur la plage ils ne découvrent aucune
pollution
qu'ensuite adolescent quand ils 0 ont
navigué ils puissent aller droit devant
eux sans se poser de questions en toute
liberté
et puis enfin peut-être un jour qu'ils
aient la chance de pouvoir mettre un
masque et un tuba voir des bouteilles et
s'émerveiller devant un récif corallien
la faveur que je vous demande c'est de
partager avec moi une photo ou une image
qui vous fait vibrer qui vous aspire
quand vous pensez à la mer
la mer c'est une infinie source
d'inspiration pour les artistes
les musiciens les poètes les écrivains
les peintres et photographes
moi c'est cette photo de d'oiseaux
marins qui me fait vibrer cette vie qui
survole l'océan en toute liberté
alors si vous le play partager quelque
chose qui vous fait vibrer avec moi
parce qu'ensemble nous pouvons agir pour
l'océan merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]